cause continues uh and that cause is
clear
and we have not only been forthright
we've also been very prescriptive
in terms of what we're looking for in
order
to provide an architecture of advancing
uh recovery here in the state of
california and supporting working
families
uh working poor and supporting those uh
that may have fallen through the cracks
or not getting the support of
unemployment insurance or the pua
support
uh and that may be more permanently
harmed
by this pandemic as it relates to uh
their employability going forward so
on all fronts we're putting together
next year's budget
we have an economic framework moving
forward we signed a number of bills and
advanced the number of
economic and workforce development
efforts in our budget
we'll continue to do more of that and
will continue to
re-enforce the imperative of getting
more federal supports including ppp
for our businessmen and women including
extending unemployment
and poa insurance including more direct
workforce training
supports to get people the skills they
need
to get back into the economy as quickly
as they possibly can
alex michaelson fox 11.
thank you governor and congratulations
on the appointment today
i have a question about coronavirus
you've been pretty clear
from the beginning of this crisis about
the seriousness of copit19
the president this afternoon tweeting
out that he's going to be leaving walter
reed and saying quote
feeling really good don't be afraid of
covid
don't let it dominate your life we've
developed under trump administration
some really good drugs and knowledge
i feel better than i did 20 years ago do
you agree with that
sort of messaging about covenant and do
you think that could be dangerous for
people
it's a political season so it doesn't
surprise me or anybody but
certainly has impacted the president's
life quite directly
and quite significantly he's been in the
hospital the last
number of days 200 plus thousand people
have lost their lives lost a loved one
i watched today mayor garcia
of long beach on a national show
reminding us
he lost both of his parents to coven 19.
how deadly this disease remains and
continues to be
i reminded you a moment ago and i'll do
it again 21 states
are seeing an increase in the
transmission rates other countries are
experiencing
what was predicted a second wave to
minimize to negate
to dismiss this pandemic is anything but
what it is
a deadly pandemic deadly disease
that's impacting lives destroying
families
as well as our economy i don't think
advances
collective cause of bringing this
country back together
kcbs
hi governor thanks um you know it was
only a decade ago that a lot of people
would describe california as
ungovernable and now
growing numbers say it's unlivable i
personally know
several people who have decided to move
to other states they've just had enough
of worsening wildfires and rolling
blackouts and
smoky days when their kids can't go
outside and there are ads airing on our
radio station now for
a company serving people who want to
leave the bay area what do you say to
the people who are
ready to give up on california i've
lived here
half a century i've heard this pretty
much every decade you referenced a
decade ago and
in this last decade we've been enjoying
economic prosperity the likes of which
few states have enjoyed last five years
3.8 average gdp growth 120 consecutive
months
of net job creation record surpluses
record
reserves record level of business
startups
innovation more scientists more
researchers more nobel laureates
in this state than any other state in
this nation all of that
remains fine a system of higher
education anywhere
in the world the balance sheet of the
state is extraordinary
our competitiveness is second to none
the international status that we enjoy
as a brand and our capacity to compete
also
uh is best of class and so i'm very long
this state
very confident in our ability to
continue to prosper well into the future
and i would encourage you and many
others just to look back as an example
a proof point a point of reference to a
edition of time magazine that was done
in 1994
the entire special edition i was saying
california's best days are behind it
they talked about the mass exodus they
talked about wildfires in this state
they talked about other things that were
rather curious as it relates to the
diversity
uh of our state at the time and some of
the xenophobia nativism
that was alive and well we recovered
as a state we worked through that as we
always do
i saw today there was a happiness index
put out
california remaining one of the happiest
states
for individuals to live in in the united
states of america so we're challenged
at this time as every state in this
country challenged at this time in
states that haven't uh had to struggle
through
this pandemic and the economic
consequences are beginning to struggle
through this
pandemic and its economic consequences i
was on the phone the other day
and listening in to the governor of
colorado
they were talking about historic
wildfires in their
majestic state it's not unique to
california
west coast the united states of being
impacted
by these challenges by these conditions
but as i always say and
forgive me i'll say it yet again it's
our decisions
not conditions that determine our faith
and future and i have confidence
in our capacity to compete to thrive not
just survive
in the next number of years uh and i
would just encourage
folks that are leaving uh to consider uh
the fact
that this state six seven months ago
was dominating in so many different
sectors and those core tenants of the
state
remain still as alive and enlivened
as they ever have been despite some of
these situational challenges that we
face
thank you governor i have two questions
first of all what's the latest
on the reopening plan for disneyland and
other theme parks
and secondly when it relates to this new
equity metric
uh some county officials have voiced
concern
that this metric might hold them back
from reopening businesses or schools
at a time when reopening could bring an
economic boost to their communities
i'm just curious why your administration
is introducing this metric at this time
and
are you concerned at all that it could
slow economic recovery well we
introduced the construct of the metric
when we put out the tiered status in
fact it was part of the original
presentation
uh the original announcement so it's not
particularly new
but i would just say this if you believe
in growth and you don't believe in
inclusion
then we're going to leave a lot of
people behind and one of the things we
value as a state
is inclusion and we believe that we're
all better off when we're all
better off leaving communities behind
in order to gain your testing and your
case rates
i don't think is right and so our
approach
is about making sure that we are doing
justice
to our diverse communities and that
we're not just gaining a system
to paint a much more rosy picture that
may be for some
but not all members of a community
particularly
a specific county now as it relates to
your specific
frame that some counties are concerned
you'll hear tomorrow
dr galley will come out with the new
updates on the tiered
uh status in the movement and our
broad strokes belief think uh looks to
be
in this frame meaning the equity measure
interestingly may help
advance the cost of reopening in some
states because some counties
are actually doing more in that respect
and that's being counted
in to their capacity to move more
expeditiously
through the tier so in fact it may be
something that advantages an economic
opening
but does so in a way that brings more
people
uh to light and more inclusion
to bear and so we believe that a core
value and we believe this framework is
an appropriate one
jeremy white politico
hey governor uh thanks for taking my
question uh can i ask the thing that i
think's on
everyone's minds which is who you are
picking to get to the world series this
year
just kidding um as you noted ballots
have gone out
around the state today i know you've
been busy with still signings and budget
stuff
but i'm curious to know can we expect to
see you hitting the trail for about
initiatives you've endorsed or for uh
congressional candidates for the
president
um in the coming weeks no i well i
appreciate that question and it's it's
one
that i've had a number of people have
asked me and we just haven't made the
determination so
i think you framed it and i appreciate
you framing it as you did as it relates
to
what we've had to address in terms of
bill signing
some of these wildfires addressing
trying to get the stability addressing
the issues
related transmission of kovid so
campaigning
politics has not been top of my mind
that said now that the ballots have
dropped now that we are moving into this
final sprint
in this last month i recognize the
imperative and importance of that
will make some assessment and
determination but my fundamental
responsibility my top priority
is my job governing the state of
california and not campaigning
uh for others to the extent
campaigning for causes that impact
and benefit the state of california we
certainly
uh look forward to doing more and saying
more in that space
final question angela hart kaiser help
news
thank you governor um the president's
positive covid test has raised some
questions about your own covid testing
just wanted to ask you so previously on
a few occasions you've said that you did
not want to get tested
to preserve those tests and then later
you were tested which turned out
negative so
um how many times have you been tested
in total
and what were the results are you
regularly tested
uh and i'm also wondering if you're
planning on perhaps changing your
thinking about this approach uh given uh
the president's
positive test yeah no we continue to
practice what we preach in terms of mass
squaring
relating to issues of highly vulnerable
events and communities visiting prisons
meeting with president himself a few
weeks back
those were appropriate places to be
tested uh protocols
well established uh so we'll continue to
maintain our vigilance we'll continue
uh not to send mixed messages as it
relates to
importance and the imperative of wearing
masks or minimize
the impact of this disease on people's
health and
lives that are lost and will continue to
update people
as it relates to the health of our state
and health this economy uh and as it
relates to my health
we've been tested on multiple occasions
tested negative and
if i was tested positive i would have
the responsibility
and you would have the right to know and
that would be forthcoming
well with that let me thank all of you
uh
for uh your responsiveness
to this pandemic and the good work that
all of you have done 40 million of us
strong
uh that have once again moved these
transmission rates down
i should just note in closing that the
2.6
7 day positivity rate is the lowest we
have recorded
in the state since april that's very
encouraging
but again we're seeing a plateauing
of the rate of decline and we're seeing
parts of the state that continue uh to
struggle as it relates they are
effective
and as it relates to the transmission of
this disease and that's why it's
incumbent upon all of us to be vigilant
and maintain the status all the hard
work that you have advanced to continue
it
so we can get through this get to a
vaccine take care everybody
you